[موسيقى
] لقد زرت بادري كارينجتون في دبلن ،
فأنا الآن أسافر غربًا عبر
البلاد لأخذ بعض
الدورات التدريبية الأكثر روعة
التي تأمل أن تجدها هي
الطريق الأطلنطي البري
الممتد من كورك في الجنوب إلى
دونيجال في الشمال
على بعد 1500 ميل ، إنها واحدة من أطول
المسارات التي يمكن العثور عليها في مسارات جولات ساحلية في العالم ،
وقد ألهمت هذه المناظر الطبيعية الوعرة
الشعراء الفنانين
ومهندسي الجولف بالفعل ، وهناك
بعض الدورات التدريبية الرائعة على طول
الساحل الغربي لإيرلندا
، وفي حين أن أمثال كرة الباليه لاينش
قد تكون عربة وواترفيل من بين أكثر الدورات شهرة ،
ولسبب وجيه
هناك العشرات من أفضل الملاعب الأخرى
التي
تقدم تجربة جيدة للعب الجولف ،
محطتنا الأولى كليفتون في مقاطعة
جالواي ، على جانب كل طريق في
كونيمارا ، من
المحتمل أن تأتي  عبر شيء
جميل جدًا مثل هذا ،
ليس هذا صحيحًا ، إنه
كونيمارا
جولفلينكس ، تم بناؤه في عام 1973 بعد دعوة
للعمل من قبل المجتمع
المحلي ووالدهم الكاهن بيت.  r waldron
[موسيقى]
هذا هو الجولف في أعظم مشاعره
الدرامية
الجامحة ، لقد عاد إلى الأساسيات
أنت وكرة الجولف الخاصة بك ضد الطبيعة الأم ،
بغض النظر عن الطقس الذي تقرر أن
ترميه عليك
، فقد صممه المهندس المعماري الراحل إيدي
هاكيت أعظم دورة في أيرلندا على
عكس بعض
فضل معاصرو هاكيت العمل كمصممين
من الماضي البعيد
يتحركون بأقل قدر ممكن من التربة كما قال هو
نفسه ذات مرة ،
أجد أن الطبيعة هي أفضل مهندس
معماري أحاول تزيين ما يقدمه الرب الطيب
[الموسيقى]
عليك  تحلى بالصبر ، عليك أن
تتطلع إلى التحدي التالي لأن كل يوم
هو يوم مختلف
عن الرياح الشمالية ، ورياح السكك الحديدية الجنوبية
عليك فقط
قبولها واللاعبين ليس
قميصك وملعب الجولف القصير عليك
أن تلعب العناصر
التي تلعبها  هذا المكان عادة ما تحضره ،
إنه
وجبة فطور.  توقف عدد من الأشخاص عند منتصف الطريق
لتناول القهوة المغذية ،
اذهب العب في الليل وتناول الطعام مرة أخرى
ودردش مرة أخرى ، إنه يوم ثماني ساعات ، حسنًا ،
إنه يوم كامل من العمل
جيدًا الآن أعرف لماذا يسمونه
بالطريقة الأطلسية
البرية وربما تغلبت الطبيعة الأم  أنا
في المنطقة الخضراء الأخيرة
اليوم ولكن هناك شيء واحد ستجده دائمًا
حول لعبة الجولف في هذا الجزء من العالم
وهو أنه يستحق دائمًا إعادة الزيارة
بينما تشق طريقك حول أيرلندا
بلعب الجولف ، فمن السهل
جدًا أن تنشغل في لعبتك الخاصة ولكن
أثناء سفرك من دورة إلى أخرى ،
أعتقد أنه من المهم حقًا التوقف
بين الحين والآخر والاستمتاع
ببعض المناظر الرائعة
المتوفرة إلى حد كبير في كل
زاوية وهذا
مثال كلاسيكي على دير كايل مور